southwest medical hospice care the
sponsors of this segment provide the
right care at the right time and with
the right companion
well i am debbie and i'm originally from
iowa and i moved to las vegas two years
ago actually from clearwater beach i
became a hospice volunteer because of
the
relationship we had with hospice when my
parents were both sick
i learned quickly the value the
information that they had they helped us
keep our parents in our home
with our the hospice services
and i knew that when the time was right
i would be donating and volunteering my
time volunteering has taught me a lot
about life and it's really the small
things that we do that can have a really
big impact on not only who we're
volunteering with but who we're
volunteering for
and i've also learned that you need to
live your dash i have a little necklace
on here that says live your dash and we
all have a birth date we all have a
death date but it's how you live in
between
you got to make those days count
as a hospice volunteer i have chosen to
be in direct contact with the patients
and that has put me in contact with
their families i like building that
relationship with them
they look at you as part of their family
and in caring for their loved one and
it's been a really
big bonus for me to make some friends
out of this volunteering experience as
well
her involvement with our family during
this hospice journey has meant the world
to us and i just know that
one of the most challenging things about
the journey is the isolation you feel as
a caregiver and debbie specifically as i
can talk about her as she was our
volunteer i have always said
the juxtaposition of what she does as a
volunteer is not lost on me
you're looking at somebody who is bubbly
who is i always say debbie is like
sunshine personified she comes in with
this huge smile and this bubbly
personality and no matter what kind of
night we had before caring for um
my father-in-law and my mother-in-law i
always knew that we would feel better
after she came because she just brings
the gift of um
being
and i think that's sometimes difficult
as a caregiver because as a caregiver
you're
do they have their medicine are they
clean are they fed you've got all this
checklist of things to do and i think
the one thing that the hospice volunteer
brings that's very unique is that
presence just to be able to be with that
loved one and that's a precious gift
it's a precious gift for the caregiver
to be able to get out or get your hair
cut go
get
take the dog for a walk whatever it is
that you need to do to clear your head
and it's a precious gift for the one
who's being cared for too i would
definitely encourage people to
volunteer with southwest medical you
might not have the gifts and talents to
be a direct companion or
contact with the patient but there's
behind the scenes administrative things
maybe you have a gift of a pet music or
art therapy
there's um
running errands for patients in the
family you know so there are lots of
ways that you know we're a big puzzle we
we fit together
we want to thank southwest medical
hospice care for sponsoring this segment
and to avenir memory care for letting us
film this piece in their facilities for
more information call 702-671-1111